how's of guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 15 of the sparking
game engine series in which we make a
game engine from scratch in C++ so last
time we had the joy of reading free
images stuff so just to refresh everyone
what we had was has been a while like
it's been hasn't been that long but it's
been like a day or so we had this test
let me just open this in paint.net I
think if I just go at it yeah okay so we
had this texture and I read it in but
the problem we had was yeah so we were
reading it in and it was looking a bit
weird because 0 71 83 like that is
definitely not the color of the final
pixel in here because that color was 183
183 so it turns out that it with this
color obviously as you saw in that video
and it actually read it in it seems from
this last corner to there so I think so
I'm not 100% sure so if we just make
this white for example we should see 255
255 255 that's one thing I didn't verify
last time that this was actually the
last pixel and snot reading it like this
because that would be even worse that
would be just weird so let's just
quickly check out that it is 255 last
one it is ok good so there we go
it looks like at least we know how it's
loading it in now if this is a question
of whether or not we want to pass it
into OpenGL like that we totally could
because right now if I just look at this
I mean yeah it looks pretty good
whatever we can it is in reverse order
if we did want to change it or something
X is being read fine but if we did want
to change it or something we could
simply reverse this whole process so
pitch right now is what is pitch what is
pitch so pitch would be 24 actually no I
think it let's just go check out pair
chip ok pitcher is 24 so pitch is the
same as bits per pixel so if we did want
to do something like this we could so
how we're doing this and what's this so
this is 2 ok so it looks like it's the
other way around as well
yeah that's all right little endian huh
well um well we could this is so bizarre
it's fine though it's fine what we could
do is what is this this pixel is totally
fine we could just basically set this to
be yeah I don't know there's a few
different ways we could do this if we
wanted it we wanted to to reverse this
we could just simply change the order of
of the vertical reading of it
which would mean that by the pixel of
course needed to be it we would have to
read these bits of it separately and
actually point to the end of bits which
would be a bit more interesting so do we
know the length of it it's just going to
be with times height times so pitch art
is okay so that is the bits what because
it's being added on to that is so
bizarre maybe that's why we weren't
reading all of it last time but that is
kind of weird but if we have something
like this it should necessarily wrong
maybe it's not that I don't know this is
such a weird format that it's just it's
weird because we seem to be doing it
correctly but well anyway um there's a
few different ways we could we could
actually change the the way that this is
being read and whatnot wait what oh no
of course that's not working um that's
not that's pixel but not oh no I thought
that was bits um what do we have before
we just got that in mind
so we're converting what what is that
doing because we're advancing it why do
they have to make this image library so
confusing seriously it's just not it's
not even all right anyway we're going to
all that aside we now know how we now
know how we can load images and whatnot
so this is our like our image loading
test all we need to do now is to
basically put it into an OpenGL texture
so if we just shut this off for a minute
so that we lose all that and let me just
shut off that breakpoints where we need
it and all those go hit it or anything
but this is what we had before in terms
of actually game cool we had this thing
we had that was with groups and whatnot
let's start with creating a texture soda
bread a texture class in graphics we'll
hit up new item which type in texture
I'm going to include a rather pragma
once it's going to include our name
space which is our key graphics
and cloth texture okay oops so this is
going to represent a pretty simple
texture this when we move on to arrays
of textures is going to be slightly
different we'll do that probably did
today as well but later on well actually
for the video it won't be today for the
stream it will be today but let's
quickly include glue and I think that's
probably all we'll need
so one thing we might want to do is hold
on to let me just include stuff like
string we probably don't exactly need to
but one clue - one thing that we will do
is we will hold on to the path to the
texture that's great for debugging
purposes if not we can probably make
some kind of release configuration that
gets rid of it if you are concerned
we'll have a texture ID which is the
OpenGL kind of texture that we need to
have and finally I think we'll just have
we'll probably have just hold on to the
width and height okay so when you create
a texture we've got to think about this
as well but usually when you create a
texture you'll probably want to take in
a path and that's probably about it so
we should be able to take in the path to
an actual we should be able to just take
in a path to an actual image so what I
mean by that is you just specify like a
PNG and then it should be able to work
out everything including the width and
height from it and you will be able to
do that just fine we'll have a
destructor and let's see so we should
probably have getters and stuff so we'll
have our bind we'll have our unbind
right so this will bind and unbind the
texture we might actually safai a way to
pop it into its particular texture slot
as an active texture we'll do that when
we do to actually arrays and one off and
now we shouldn't we shouldn't have to do
to deal with that and then we'll finally
make
an inline unsigned int GATS width which
will just return wet I should call that
and wet oops
and the same thing will have for the
height which is Papa Const here as well
and it should probably return a Const on
the side and doesn't really have to I
mean I just kind of assuming that it's
not going to be changed but we might
want to increment the gap width just
locally for some reason or a / - I don't
know but we'll just keep it calm like
this just to I think that's probably
going to be the more the more like I
guess correct way of doing things
because when you do retrieve the width
it shouldn't be something that changes
because you can't change it so you
shouldn't the illusion that it changes
anyway that's probably more about how
actual how stuff actually works and more
about programming practices than actual
functionality but let's have a Glu in so
it is it is an unsigned int I believe
only like shader stuff really have will
have load only like really like shader
stuff and I was going to say more or
less like uniform uniform like locations
and whatnot return negative numbers and
signed in spurt most OpenGL stuff is
unsigned okay cool so let's grab free
image let's pop it over here it's going
to be our image loading thing I might
write an actual free image seems like
semi easy to use though so I don't think
it's now no it doesn't it's it's not
that good but anyway it doesn't seem too
difficult to you so I don't think it'll
be something that we have to abstract
ourselves and actually put out into like
an image loading utility class we could
have something like that in fact I think
we just will just because it'll it might
be a bit better so we'll have like
something like
image alert or something
I don't know I'm really tempted just a
switch convention but yeah let's do it
the whole whole reason that we've got
stuff in upper case and lower case is
because Visual Studio refused to rename
batch render up to your lower case so I
guess we're somewhat in that land now
but we'll just have a pragma once
namespace Sparkie we'll just have this
normal animal namespace and then we'll
just make a static let's see so this
should return a bunch of pixels
apparently it likes returning byte
though so if we grab free image right I
don't really know but is just a bunch of
unsigned chars by the way we should
probably look at in our documents we do
have in libs under free image there is
an actual example of getting into where
sublime text there is an actual example
of getting into OpenGL and that's this
and apparently all they do is they pass
in the bits just by as an unsigned byte
but just by using it seems the get bits
and that's it
they don't even that's all they do so
really we should just be getting that so
static byte pointer will just go static
what I think static void load image or
grab the I think what we really need is
the path
so this will be a con Strafford's we
really just need the path which actually
I'll just pass in like this the path
then we need pixels unsigned and with
unsigned and I'm passing these as
pointers just because I kind of prefer
that style a bit more because that
almost that basically tells me that I
okay it's actually going to modify those
things so again we could return pixels
as well as there's so much that's just
so much we could do but we'll just leave
it like this for now okay cool so this
is what we had in fact I'm just going to
steal most of this so we verified that
it totally works now let's steel pretty
much all of this and that's really all
we needed to do right yeah so if we
steal this lets get rid of most of this
stuff let's just change this to like
it's like proper like more than kind of
so bits are these pixels it's actually
going to reassign them though might not
be the best way to actually might be
better to just do this free honest
just because there then I'll anyway so
with an hi we don't need remember we're
passing that in through here so OpenGL
is texture idea we don't need that so
path right yeah filenames probably a
better name v ok okay so we'll do stuff
like return null pointer check the
plug-in yeah we'll do all this stuff why
not
oops okay bits is our result so bite
results and then we'll set width and
height appropriately for them order 10
hours old alright so that looks pretty
good
there's our actual setting everything
else should read it in pretty well we've
basically tried this and it seems it
seems okay but if we pop out into can't
believe I'm just searching convention
midway through it's a bit annoying
really but what am i doing I'm closing
out all my classes I'm not gonna dwell
too much on that anymore
okay texture was graphics texture are we
have an implication file yeah okay cool
so let's make an implementation file now
let's cook let's go you item table cloth
texture include texture
name space Sparky on time today
apparently as well I'm not even looking
at my keyboard it's all hidden here name
space graphics please don't change
everything oh you did it anyway you're
annoying I ask you girls video I suck
please
okay texture texture which takes in I
probably just go falling so the file
should my way that's a show okay so
that's going three for our filename what
we'll do now is pretty much just load
this in one thing I wanted to mention
was yeah so all we'll do is we'll set
down faster ID to low okay which should
basically take care of everything
including our width and height and one
not so if I make the load will make a
destructor as well so destructor will
have to actually release the pixels will
probably do that straight away though as
well that's something that I probably
should have mentioned so in you might
have noticed you know in our image load
utility thing you would have probably
noticed that we actually reallocated the
world this is it doesn't seem like this
actually does anything like is in I
don't know how it works internally but
it free image unload is probably what
actually deletes this so and that
actually needs the Dib so I'm I'm not
sure if we can do this I'm not sure if
this will actually delete I should
really look at the source code or the
documentation but free image unload
might actually delete these bits so it
could be a bit dangerous once we pass
them into OpenGL it's okay but again I
don't know it might just unload it from
memory but not
delete the bits maybe they get put into
their own memory I don't know we'll
figure this out though so we won't use a
destructor or anything just yet but this
this looks like it probably will need to
get deleted at some at some point and
this isn't the source code so I have no
idea whe i should look at the source
code if i am doubtful but i'm not to
doubtful right now and it shouldn't be
really too much of a problem so if we
pop into texture so what i'm saying is
will leave the disruptor blank for now
because i really don't know how free
image works but we'll have our load
right which returns an unsigned int and
i think that's all of our methods right
I'll bind and unbind okay
one comment down quickly as well so bind
and unbind they're going to be as usual
very simple gel bind texture gel texture
QD and MT ID
okay cool
so ah Lord okay
so Lord is what's actually going to do
most of our heavy lifting will include
our utility I might actually put the
utils into their own kind of into their
own kind of like project basically and
then we can just refer to them with
these brackets and we don't have to do
paths and they can be maintained
separately as kind of spark utils or
something I don't know but we'll talk
about that stuff in the maintenance
episode of course not the not these real
episodes so to load this stuff it seems
that all we really need to do is if we
go byte will go by pixels it doesn't
even matter they can probably not be
they can learn have to allocate them or
anything then we'll go ahead oh actually
that's our results so we can just go
equals image load image slowly measures
now load image the file name is going to
be M file name which will probably have
to revert into a C string the we might
have to put that into its own thing I
don't know we'll see
and then width and height is just going
to be width high okay there we go
so that looks pretty good that's how
going to hopefully do all of our heavy
lifting for us and that really should be
all we need to do from this side of
things so apparently all we need to do
next is set up the textures properly as
in how OpenGL will do it and then just
yeah just called GL text text image 2d
with all of our parameters and that's it
and see it unloads it after which is so
free free free images copy of the data
so is it implying that it is a copy this
is very confusing
we'll see we might actually have to turn
this into a class or something so that
we can destroy the class or something
later so much confusion we'll see we'll
figure it out okay
don't you worry okay so we'll go ahead
and just allocate everything so if we
have our result which is our ID we'll go
ahead and Jen gel Jen textures just one
and results okay well binds the texture
results unbind it and okay and then all
we have to do is we can set a few
parameters so I like is that I'll i
usually like to set parameters such as
do we want it to be anti aliased
or not that's usually one of the more
popular parameters I guess so basically
if you change your in filter attachement
filter and your mag filter to be you can
change them to either Ethier r2 ether to
either be linear which means they will
linear interpolate between pixels if the
thing is too large or you can change it
to me like nearest which will just go to
the nearest pixel obviously which will
result in the fully like no anti-icing
at all so you're going for something
like minecraft low resolution textures
with you can see each pixel clearly and
it's not you know whatever then nearest
is what you want otherwise you want
linear obviously we will support both of
them depending on what the person using
the engine decides right now because
we're testing we'll just go nearest well
rule we have to set this up somehow
um but for now this is how the cookie
will crumble we'll go ahead and set up
our so text image 2d is what we can
actually use to specify our data so our
target of course is just the same as it
always has been
now the level will be zero there aren't
we might talk about this stuff we don't
really need to talk about this stuff at
all because we're not going to be doing
stuff like 3d textures and there and
texture rights just because they're a
little bit weird and it's better to just
do our own arrays of textures and manage
that ourselves internal format I'm
assuming it will read
it's Eve might really desire to be
hydrated as I do be a it's going to be a
bit difficult luckily we can query the
actual pixels for something like that
and we'll definitely deal with that for
now
right now I just want this to work their
width and height is going to be M width
and M height and it looks like what does
it want it just wants Glu and I'm sure
our size eyes yeah that's right which
arguments okay so we'll just change for
the type of being all cool urban jail
we'll change this to GL sighs I and
we'll do the same for a load image
okay and it'll head us for image which
has their in jail had it so notice what
it is great okay so there we go and then
we need what's next we need border so no
border of course a format which is
probably just going to be RGB again then
the format which is going to be unsigned
byte and finally the actual data which
will just be pixels now at this point in
time when we're done we should basically
delete pixels now the problem there is
none multi letting them as because I
don't know who manages their memory and
we might have to just free using free I
don't know what's going on so we'll have
to definitely verify that and whatnot
that is that should be the end of the
story let's quickly run through this and
see how it works though so if I go ahead
and I decide to make a new texture by
just pulling so we'll go sauce graphics
texture and then we will go ahead and
just create a new texture say here fish
probably stick together here texture is
zoom in a bit
attach the texture so cast up Andrea I
think was what we had in our directory
here where are we so Visual Studio
Projects Sparky yeah so in here test up
Andrea great um yeah so what is running
through this so let's just run this and
see what happens okay didn't even build
Tasha load must return a value yes it is
it must so we were and release might
really wouldn't even tell us that
because it's not ready narrow okay um I
want to step in here and I know I don't
I absolutely don't want it in there okay
so pixels it seems like that again it's
hard to read these things I'm assuming
that's correct though width and height
is 8 by 8 so that worked let's just see
if OpenGL is happy with it OpenGL seems
happy with it okay great
so let's actually test it out now that's
the best way to do things so one thing
you'll notice is our image is yep that
was correct top to bottom
we'll need to push in a few
texture coordinates and see how this
works though so we don't actually
support a ship or not yet do we
um can we
simple render a road this I think so I
think so I think we can just go ahead
and let's simple render a row at this so
simple 2d renderer simple when you're
specify anything more simple dot add is
that other thing I don't know how this
thing works anymore we haven't
maintained it for a while I'll submit
that's right oh it's on the layout
yeah we don't need a layout so simple
dot submit renderable will be a new
sprite so we'll go zero zero four for
maths back for oh we don't need a color
because it's going to be a texture so
let's just do this for now and then
simple we need to do that every frame we
don't want to create a sprite every
frame them so test texture
so simple just submit test texture
simple dot flush let's just say for that
appears on the screen should Oh what
what what just happened that definitely
should not have happened is our render a
broken
and I guess a methyl OC okay flush is
definitely broken access violation
relocation yes so submit and it will DQ
it hmm interesting
let's go into there and see exactly what
went wrong so sprite what does that give
us that's definitely valid so get VI or
bind
so what's MVX ra it's not telling me cuz
it's aligned so bind is going to fail
isn't it yeah that's mega rolling oh
well we are surprised should have done
that though ah why did we change the
right our goodness we did our simple
render is not going to work anymore
because we broke everything it doesn't
have an actual vertex store anymore okay
that's fine I guess we can batch render
test it that is annoying there I don't
think we'll be able to test this
properly without actually what we could
always just OpenGL it I guess like that
let's just lull it and when I say at
Lola I really mean Lola because we're
just going to use OpenGL immediate mode
that works with shaders right to not
only going to immediate motor we're
going to aquatic immediate motor it's
kind of sad that we don't have a simple
way of drawing things anymore but I'll
fix that eventually okay zero zero is so
hilarious we're going to go [ __ ] wise we
go to anti-clockwise the questions are
just all there but you know
up is that way right there it is good
yes it does work as great as I was
getting of course it does
okay so let's let's just try this out so
to actually dot vine we need to set up a
few texture coordinates luckily we can
just do that by using text record I kind
of remand it is this is just text record
2d or slightly arts tax isn't it Tess
chord
2f so 0 0 I believe that that'll be like
1 1 1 and 1 everything's bound yes let's
hop into our shaders real quick so we're
just testing whether or not textures
will actually work will they will they
not it's just it's all over the place
and it's difficult how do we access them
I think it's gel texture coordinate 2d
or something GLSL 1.1 tax awards you
please tell me how to do it back in the
day
of course we no one did it back in the
day without though I wonder if we don't
specify shader weather or just it should
just work right lulz
so if we it's not going to override the
shader though oh okay well we won't do
in the trader will just this is
ridiculous
I forgot about the whole thing there is
a way to access it in the shader
definitely but what's just this'll
probably 1282 us yeah no and it's still
the shadows still okay let's just let's
just actually write the shader for
[ __ ] remember how to so let's stop our
our renderers let's basically just get
rid of all this
okay just so we're rendering only that
so now it should oh that's an arrow well
either is an arrow we're just gonna have
a shader so let's enable a shader okay
good
that seems legit let's go into our
shader which is basic top frag which
just get our fragment shader we need to
take in bunch of texture coordinates ok
now we're not we don't we can just go
ahead and say we do need a do we even
need that I don't remember what the I
don't remember what the GLSL like 1.1
I'm going to have to quickly google this
because I just I don't remember I just I
don't remember what they are
okay so no no care communication no just
tell me what the different variables are
we'll just look at like an easy simple
texture let's just look that hopefully
it's actually old-school this is a waste
of time
honestly I should've just ended the
episode here we go so GL is that being
built though he seems to be setting into
something they're multi - boards GL so
just gelled text chord s T
okay maybe that will work I don't know
this is I mean legacy land it's annoying
me so what do we have here
that okay I don't even know if it's all
laughter we've committed to it already
so I guessing I need to pass that
uniform in manually yes I do
so shade it up a naval shader dot set
here for one eye text value zero nope
what's up I've healthcare pilot no no no
sheets okay I'm so embarrassed doing
this um yeah but then we can't use that
other stuff because oh I should never
have done this I should this is such
it's a drag color this is sight this was
such a mistake on my part
holy guacamole this stuff probably isn't
even a theme yet can I just use 140
that's the thing right
oh so many hours but that's deprecated
up to 120 hmm
I will make this work in blocks require
of course it doesn't know what n is yet
um does it know what those kind of
styles of comments are yes yes Everson I
know that's undefined
I've destroyed my shader oh it worked
but that's not my texture at all let's
say yellow it's yellow that's like one
of it though let's just change it to
like this is so I should not I should
definitely have not done this because I
have no idea how to make it work anyway
because yeah okay so it's reading like
one pixel of it the technical one that's
probably wrong
oh this was mistake because I don't know
how to deal with it um I mean that looks
right but you know oh this was
definitely not good yes so like is that
what is that I'm learning a fair bit of
legacy GL right now I don't think I ever
did textures and in that all really used
much of legacy jail so that should be
the test coordinates right
are these taking in the right are these
correct let's quickly verify
that's the back for right so let's just
man that is not it's not correct
probably Oh zoster um that's wrong
probably that's okay so disaster I mean
it's not working
so the tactic one it's probably not how
do you read those things this is
ridiculous this is much ridiculous um
this is the most ridiculous episode in
the world oh goodness me well I guess
I'm doing this now oh goodness okay you
guys are gonna love this um Oh No mmm
okay let's let's do it let's just do it
we've we've gone this far let's just do
it well was it we were on 120 right
that means we lose everything uniforms
were still thing by heart we don't need
that we don't need that okay maybe this
isn't that bad
I can just revert my shape it's all I
know I goodbye
okay does that still work oops
okay positions not a thing
how do i is it just gel position yes it
is okay good so this looks pretty good
and you might not be able to do this oh
okay I'll hold over these I promise um
okay so that's totally good
let's take in a a vector so apparently
just do that or you can do that and then
we'll have a varying vector PC cannot
believe I'm doing this
ok let's let's see it's a work site the
magic word is what is it it is GL vertex
at rib to f GL get the Trib location
this is so old-school goodness me shada
dot like what's the program shader dot
I'm shader ID foot x and y oh so this is
not using - port really anymore really
this is so absolutely ridiculous and
it's called tax core right
maybe this legacy stuff is hard this
works I'm going to be so surprised
Oh topic 2 is the shade or a
neighborhood it is what's why you 12 you
doing me which probably just save the
data compiles properly no it did that's
bad so it's well ready to use me here
does it yep
okay maybe can find that text cord is
that what we called it attribute the
vector tax cord why why are you not
working
mmm so nothing's wrong with the shader
apparently so please see ah why you're
not working well let's hear it it is not
that it matters but why 1282 me what am
i doing this is legit right yeah
I'm quoting myself that's right so I'm
looking at this by the way because I
literally have never done this stuff in
such old versions of OpenGL and I'm
highly regretting even doing this so see
so you're doing that how are you
so it is text forward zero equals maybe
that's what I should have done yes
so it's this so that's in vertex shader
I'm going to I'm so mad okay so once
again and I'm just I'm determined at
this point that in vertex shader 122
put on semicolon okay good so now we go
back to this I'll stop working there
it's not working why is not working
that's so annoying where are you you
stackoverflow thing hmm
what's this it's design or maybe I need
to set up the architecture maybe that's
it I don't think that's it but legacy
land is mean
so what was this giving me nothing now
maybe the positions wrong I doubt it
but it could be cool that's interesting
that's okay the plot thickens where are
you getting your position from that
let's try this
that's an era now his jail position is a
thing right
well this is another one of these
useless episodes oh I'm thinking of just
giving up now so why are you crying well
where is my oh because I don't think I'm
setting my my thing at all
yes I'm not because it's in the fudging
lair so let's head into the lair real
quick so maybe everything was just
working I was headed to lay a real quick
it's under layers
I think it's entire layer this is our
matrix
um a shader where's the shader here it
is okay
weirdness what oh that's not what I
meant
oh of course that's not what I meant um
fudge factory
what's the is it vertex position oh my
goodness okay let's look more like
old-school stuff creating a shader I
need a refresher on like jail cell like
1.4 or 2 or whatever just show me an
example shader or something please maybe
it'll be this maybe this who knows a
little quicker
Jill vertex is what I'm looking for
thank you stream yes okay
now huh hi I think we might actually be
there where did my fragment chair to go
mother duck okay um please work please
work
oh my goodness it works oh my goodness
I'm so happy now
there's our texture is it back to front
it is not even that what what what
that's the right one right mmm
is it incorrect thingy 24-bit yes looks
like it is oh well well this free image
thing is so ridiculous we might have to
just keep keep keep rolling the camera
here um let's let's let's do a few let's
do a few more like cast thingies where's
main main main here you are
where was it this or both these really
they were kind of useful
it could be [ __ ] I could be in some
are totally probably as even though the
example showed something else but let me
just verify that this stuff is correct
24 Yap 24 good I don't understand why
there's two things they're like the same
but okay so yes so the probability the
probable thing here is it's just the
other way around which is annoying but
like acceptable 1280 is an art valid it
is what well it's a thing here maybe I
need to be like hmm ah text image 2d so
internal format let's leave that at
largely B and then we'll just grab EGR
they're off
we've achieved victory and with that
we're going to end the episode and
actually implement this into our batch
render next time so I'll see you guys
next time thanks for watching it like
button if you enjoyed bye
you